Batman Arkham Knight has been highly
anticipated by bat fans everywhere but
Rocksteady and Warner Brothers copped a
fair bit of criticism when they
announced a forty-dollar DLC passed last
week without really telling us much
about it a post on Arkham Knights
official twitter feed revealed the
season pass promising only regular new
content for six months story missions
super villains and more as is the nature
of the internet the outrage spread quick
so Warner Brothers spilled the beans in
a Facebook post we now know that the
season pass will include Batgirl as a
playable character for the first time in
the series and she'll be starring in her
own prequel story set in fairly new
location the pack will also include new
narrative missions that will extend the
story lines of Batman Carlos and super
villain enemies to both before and after
the events of off tonight finally we'll
get a variety of historically iconic
Batmobiles to drive around on custom era
theme racetracks a bunch of challenge
maps and a collection of costume changes
or the floor playable characters Batman
Robin Nightwing and cattlemen let me
know what you think of the bat DLC so
far one or others have said that they'll
be releasing new information on the
season pass each month so for info on
that and everything batman arkham knight
stations to gain flow